Like when kids come over with chocolate
or candy. Yeah, thanks. Yeah, good.
I don't eat that stuff. Like you kind
of have to buy girl scout cookies.
You want to support the girl scout.
It's such a scam.
All that money goes to the manufacturer.
Apparently the girl scouts make like
20% of the the cookie money. Yeah,
they're getting fucked here. All scouts
again, fuck core. Someone came in,
some ruthless man.
Probably the MOA as it was.
That's exactly what it is. Those
are the shit. Yeah. With milk,
with a cold glass of milk.
Duncombe Yup.
Fuck yeah.
It almost tastes like a neat look at that.
Then look at it as it's
chocolatey coconut. He goodness.
Why do they have to be so bad for you?
When I was,
when I was working on a TV show,
one of the producers had a daughter who
was in the girl scouts and I guess you
win contest if you sell over,
if you saw the most cookie boxes.
So when the audience would stream out
after the show is a daily Shell and the
audience would stream out and uh,
the girl had a table set up to sell their
cookies and she was selling a hundred
boxes a day and for
every day she was there,
fucking won that contest dam.
And they would have the audience, a warm
up guy like plug it during the shell,
like after the shit, like a comedian
selling his cds after the show,
he could buy some girl scout cookies
on the way out. And all these,
these fat people from the Midwest,
they're like Kooky.
Like Marie Callender's digest
have pie. Just Pie. Just Pie.
Yup. Not even good pie. It's
good, but it's not great
considering it's all they do.
I should have eaten there. I don't think
I've ever eaten there. Maybe I it one,
I don't think I had their Pi.
That seems a weird thing.
Like come selling pies.
Yeah, Blake, good luck.
You're going to go broke.
But they're everywhere.
We know you have an element. We know you
have flour branch out a little bit. Like,
who the fuck gets famous as selling pies?
Like how genius is that company and
men's member, Edmonds intimates,
but then they, they, they broke out of,
they started doing cakes and cookies too,
but they all, they did just pies for a
long time. Dude. They used to have this,
this Ark, God damn it, this pastry. I'm
trying to think of what the hell it was,
but it had like,
like hard sugar on the outside of it.
Yeah.
And that it had some sort of creamy
sweet stuff on the inside of it. Yeah.
Holy Shit. Was it good? Yeah.
God Damn. We lived off that shit.
We had admins every night.
They had like,
they had one that had like a chocolate
filling in it and it was powdered outsize
mine. They went out of business and then
they say, oh, that was the cheese one.
That was a good one too. I remember
the cheese filled crumb. Those,
they had some ridiculously delicious
shit. Hey, what are the other big ones?
You know, I decided to fight
in a tournament once because a,
I had a crazy sugar
high from Dunkin donuts.
I'd hurt myself.
I hurt something in my crotch.
I couldn't work out for like a week or
that pulled some sort of a muscle and
there was a big tournament
that was coming up and uh, my,
all the guys that are competed with, we're
going to this tournament. I was like,
I had just fought like a week before.
I was like, I don't think I can do it.
I'm like, this doesn't feel right. I'm
just going to take the whole week off.
So I decided I'm just going to take
off, let this thing heal. And so, uh,
delivering my newspapers and
I go to Dunkin donuts and
I got this powdered lemon
filled donut.
I got one of those and I got a Boston
cream donut there, got one of those.
And I got a, I ate like three donuts
cause I'd be exhausted, tired,
drinking coffee, delivering
fucking newspapers for three hours.
And I was so jacked on sugar
and coffee that I said, fuck it.
I want to fight.
And so I drove into town like
right before everybody was leaving.
They're like, why are you here? I said,
if I'm going to fight anyway, man,
like Beavis and Butthead, I won. I won.
The tournament was a giant
tournament for me. It was big.
It was the American open. It was like
a big, it's a big deal. Wow. Yeah.
It wasn't going to do it. I got jacked
up on sugar and made a rash decision.